[Música]
históricamente los seres humanos hemos
confundido los conceptos residuos y
desechos y es que aunque ustedes no lo
crean esto no se ocurre cotidianamente
cuando terminamos una relación romántica
en la que hemos estado involucrados por
algún tiempo y pasamos de creer que no
habrá nadie como esa persona aquí tal
vez voy a ocupar su ayuda a cantar con
las cuerdas vocales un poquillo
desfasadas en los bares del pueblo una
canción que dice así a ver yo hago la
primera parte de ustedes la segunda yo
no nací para amar nadie nació para mí
exacto en la primera parte donde
nosotros creemos que no habrá nadie como
esa persona estamos en lo cierto pero
eso no nos impide luego una terapia
emocional podernos vincular con otra
persona más adelante mientras que la
cancioncita con la que me acaban de
ayudar básicamente nos consideran
desechos sociales les explico
tanto los residuos como los desechos se
producen en procesos la diferencia
radica en que los primeros los residuos
pueden valorizarse para incorporarse a
futuros procesos mientras que los
desechos una vez generados no tienen
forma alguna de incorporarse en procesos
o de valorizarse quizás nos estamos
preguntando bueno y cuáles son residuos
o desechos de los que generamos en
nuestra casa
los residuos se ven como los de la
imagen tenemos latas cajas de cartón
botellas plásticas materiales de vidrio
todos estos pueden ser reciclados e
incorporados a nuevos procesos mientras
que los desechos se parecen más como a
las bolsas de supermercado que no sé si
lo sabían pero solo tienen un tiempo de
vida media de 15 minutos los blíster de
las pastillas las jeringas y los
cartones de huevos que si no se reciclan
porque porque los residuos también
tienen una cadena o un tiempo por lo que
pasan y se valorizan y se valorizan
hasta que ya no pueden valorizar se más
es decir se convierten al final de sus
vidas en desecho
porque aparece una imagen aido del papel
higiénico porque aunque ustedes no lo
crean las personas creen algunas que el
papel higiénico usado se puede reciclar
y no no se puede reciclar
ahora se hizo un estudio costa rica en
cuatro municipios del gran área
metropolitana y se identificó según esta
caracterización que el
55.9 por ciento de los residuos que
generamos en los comercios y en nuestras
casas son biodegradables eso qué quiere
decir que se pueden comportar
seguidamente por residuos valorizables y
sólo menos del 10 por ciento en esa
caracterización llegó a ser un desecho
es decir material que debe emplearse
directamente al relleno sanitario
entonces porque seguimos viendo bolsas
de basura gigantes cuando el camión
recolector hace su ruta para mí la
respuesta es simple es por falta de
información y aunque el reciclaje y el
compostaje han venido ganando terreno
hay otro residuo silencioso que
producimos en nuestras casas cuando
hacemos actividades
de higiene personal como bañarnos
lavarnos los dientes lavar la ropa
estos se llaman aguas residuales y
aunque su nombre dice que son residuales
nos dice que son un residuo según la
política nacional de saneamiento de
costa rica- publicada en el 2016 sólo el
16 por ciento de esas aguas en nuestro
país son tratadas esto quiere decir que
el 84 por ciento de las aguas se
disponen de forma directa y sin
tratamiento previo en jardines en patios
y en cuerpos de agua tales como ríos y
quebradas
y aquí me voy a permitir contarles una
historia sobre mi primer encuentro con
aguas residuales
yo tenía 6 años soy de campo soy de sant
ramon de una familia bastante grande
donde siempre tuvimos muchos animales
el terreno de mis papás era un poquito
quebrado y abajo lo que había era un
potrero mi pasatiempo favorito cuando yo
llegaba de la escuela era tirar el
bolsillo y salir corriendo al potrero
ahí había una caseta donde estaban los
terneros mientras las vacas pastan
mecánicamente y como en forma automática
para poder bajar a donde estaban los
terneros yo tenía que saltar un cañito
que pasaba ese cañito yo nunca me
pregunté por qué pasaba por ahí pero
como el terreno era quebrado las aguas
jabonosas que salían de la casa de mis
papás corría hasta terminar en el
potrero nunca me había preguntado eso
hasta que un día después de tirar el
bolso ir corriendo el potrero justo
antes de saltar
una culebra coral iba pasando al otro
lado del cañón y en ese momento yo sabía
que si saltaba pues la culebra me podría
morder y sabía que era una culebra
venenosa y pues eso no me convenía así
que con el hada del aire espere dentro
de la culebra se iba un poquito un
poquito por la vegetación y me devolví
curiosa con el caño y me fui a
preguntarle a mi papá porque ese caño
estaba ahí y él me dijo porque las aguas
tienen que correr hacia algún lugar
y si si mis papás hubiesen tenido esta
información en ese momento quizá la
serpiente y yo no hubiésemos tenido ese
encuentro tan cercano por eso hoy quiero
hablarles de un sistema de tratamiento
de aguas residuales que es alternativo
que podemos hacer en nuestras casas que
no se ocupa demasiado espacio ni
demasiado presupuesto y que podría
ayudarnos a evitar este tipo de
accidentes en el futuro se llaman bio
jardineras estos sistemas son muy
sencillos de construir tienen español es
un mini estanques pero e
impermeabilizado hay piedras y plantas
que permiten la remoción de la materia
orgánica
y también el agua que sale después de
pasado por el sistema se puede
incorporar en procesos como lavar el
carro regar el jardín entre otras es
decir nos da un agua de calidad que no
es para consumo pero muchísimas de las
actividades que usted y yo hacemos en
nuestra casa y en la que incluimos agua
de calidad potable realmente no la
necesitan
en estos sistemas si pudiésemos ver el
agua de entrada con respecto al agua de
salida podríamos ver que la entrada es
gris un poquito oscura tiene grasa tiene
jabón
mientras que la de salida es translúcida
normalmente no tiene un olor y se puede
aprovechar para múltiples usos
[Música]
ok
nosotros en la universidad nacional
tenemos diferentes instancias que
trabajan este tipo de sistemas en
diferentes comunidades del país para eso
es importante para nosotros vincular a
todas las personas que van a ser los
dueños de estos sistemas por qué porque
cuando la universidad nacional sale de
trabajar en la comunidad difícilmente va
a poder ayudar a resolver a esa familia
algún problema que tenga labio jardinera
cuando estas personas participan en el
proceso constructivo son los dueños y
dueñas de su sistema de tratamiento cada
quien participa desde donde pueda los
niños y niñas participan también con la
capacidad que tengan llevando las
piedras sembrando poniendo piedras en el
mini estanque etcétera involucramos
también actores importantísimos como lo
son el ministerio de salud la caja
costarricense de seguro social el mismo
minae que nos ayudan a dar seguimiento a
estos sistemas una vez que el proyecto
concluya no sólo nosotros trabajamos
esto también lo hace una organización
que se llama cepes-a que tiene más de
ciento sistemas
50 sistemas perdón construidos en el
país y posiblemente ustedes estarán
preguntando si estos sistemas son solo
para el campo no la respuesta es no hay
hoteles en costa rica como lo que pueden
ver en la imagen que tienen una belleza
escénica donde parece un estanque que
realmente es un jardín vivo que está
tratando uno de estos residuos tan
importantes como lo son las aguas
residuales también hay sistemas
construidos para hospitales veterinarios
donde tenemos un poquito más complicado
las aguas porque además tienen
antibióticos antiinflamatorios y otro
tipo de medicamentos y a pesar de eso
los jardines logran crecer y prosperar
hay incluso condominios y apartamentos
en san jose que en el pequeño espacio en
donde estaba determinado para un poquito
de concreto o un poquito de sácate
tienen ahorita funcionando un sistema
esto es donde tratamos las aguas
residuales
por eso yo quería traerles esta idea
porque con esto podemos ahorrar el 30%
de la facturación de agua reducir el
costo hídrico que le está causando el
planeta a nuestros hábitos de consumo de
agua de calidad que no es necesaria
podríamos ayudar también a este tipo de
residuos que básicamente si nos vamos a
la historia del principio sería cómo ir
al psicólogo curar nuestro corazón y
vincularlos con una nueva persona pero
en el caso de las aguas residuales va a
ser pasar por la vía jardinera e
incorporarse en un nuevo proceso si
quieres saber más los invito a buscar
información sobre estas tecnologías
porque yo sé que ustedes y yo podemos
hacer el cambio muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]